[Musique]
il y a six mois nous étions des enfants c'est
qui nous sommes maintenant
cet endroit ressemble à la maison mais ce n'est pas
il n'y a rien dehors les gars nous sommes tous
seuls oh je suis vivant et maintenant il est vivant
nous voulons juste être avec vous  la maison s'il
y a la maison
les choses sont ce
qu'il en est exactement
aujourd'hui je pense à ce que tu as
perdu l'esprit c'est qu'un idiot je ne vais pas
demander le pouvoir nous allons le
prendre pas peur de toi
tu devrais être nous sommes tellement [ __ ] dedans  sur un
chaos stupide
[Musique]
ils ont trop de pouvoir
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent on ne peut pas entendre les
vêtements cannibales tuer mon fils porter ton ami
c'est ce que j'ai peur de ce que tu
veux pour moi pourquoi pas toi  cours pour moi
ce que je te veux